Speaker 1: If you thought things were already
bad for beleaguered Republican Congressman
Matt Gates, they are getting a hell of a lot
worse.
And the pressure is truly building on the
Republican Party to do something about his
continued presence in the House of Representatives.
Here's the story.
Joel Greenberg, who's a major player in this
investigation that looks at whether Matt Gates
committed all sorts of different crimes, including
possibly trafficking underage girls.
Joel Greenberg wrote in a letter that has
been obtained by The Daily Beast that he and
Matt Gates paid for sex with multiple women,
including a minor girl, 17 years of age at
the time.
In question, the letter was drafted after
Greenberg asked Roger Stone, a close ally
of Trump, remember for help obtaining a pardon.
Greenberg wanted Stone to help him get a pardon
from Donald Trump at the very end of Donald
Trump's term.
Greenberg wrote in the letter, quote, On more
than one occasion, this individual was involved
in sexual activity with several of the other
girls, the congressman from Florida's 1st
Congressional District and myself.
From time to time, gas money or gifts, rent
or partial tuition payments were made to several
of these girls, including the individual who
was not yet 18 years old.
I did see the acts occur first hand.
This is a firsthand witness and Venmo transactions,
cash app or other payments were made to these
girls on behalf of the congressman.
This is a bombshell blockbuster, alleged first
hand claim.
Now, understand that for some time now, we've
suspected that this specific allegation was
going to come out.
Why?
Well, when we learned that this Joel Greenberg
decided to cooperate with investigators, Greenberg's
lawyer, Fritz Scheller, held a hilarious press
briefing right outside a courthouse and was
asked straight up, did your client, Joel Greenberg,
introduce Matt Gates to underage girls?
Check out the then hilarious but ominous response
from Greenberg's lawyer, Fritz Scheller,
Speaker 2: asking for any kind of.
Unidentified: So I'm just going
Speaker 2: to let you sit down there so I
can look over your head and ignore that question.
I apologize.
I just can't answer that question.
I was happy those.
That was a little devious down there below.
And maybe using that, it means, you know,
so.
Speaker 1: OK, so anybody who sees that is
immediately thinking that really sounds like
something we should be looking into.
That's the furthest thing from a know that
I could imagine.
And indeed, now this letter obtained by The
Daily Beast, written by Joel Greenberg, allegedly
says exactly that.
Matt Gates and I paid women for sex.
One of those women I know was a child, was
an underage girl, 17 years old now.
For me, this is not really about prostitution.
There's an important and prescient conversation
to have about sex work and whether there should
be legalization, decriminalization, regulation
of sex work for the safety of the service
providers.
This is a big topic.
It's a bigger topic than this particular story.
This story is about the constant self incrimination
of Matt Gates, possibly statutory rape and
or trafficking of a minor, if indeed one of
the girls he met, he paid to have travel across
state lines.
And, of course, the incredible double standard
between Matt Gates, his membership in the
supposed party of family values, the Republican
Party, and this behavior in conjunction with
many Republicans continuing to defend him.
Now, that being said, the number of Republicans
coming to Matt Gates defense, that number
is shrinking in number almost daily.
Now, much of this is being denied for now.
A spokesperson for Matt Gates said to CNN,
Congressman Gates has never paid for sex,
nor has he had sex with a 17 year old as an
adult.
We'll see.
One of the even crazier parts is Roger Stone's
involvement.
That's not it's almost like a detail, but
it's actually crazy.
In a series of messages that were exchanged
over the encrypted messaging app signal that
The Daily Beast obtained, Greenberg wrote
to Stone, If I get you two hundred and fifty
thousand dollars in Bitcoin, would that help
or is this not a financial matter?
And Roger Stone replied, I understand all
of this and have taken it into consideration.
I will know more in the next 24 hours.
I cannot push too hard because of the nonsense
surrounding pardons.
And then Stone later wrote to Greenberg, I
hope you are prepared to wire me two hundred
and fifty thousand dollars because I am feeling
confident, presumably, in being able to get
Greenberg a pardon.
The pardon did not happen.
So this story does not appear to be going
away anytime soon.
It seems to be getting worse and worse for
Matt Gates.
I think Gates has benefited hugely.
In a sense, Gates has benefited from Joe Biden
getting so many things done that the right
wing media attention and media attention in
general has been on a lot of right wingers
trying to find any way to attack Joe Biden.
And it's pulled attention away from Matt Gates.
I expect the tension to get back to Matt Gates
maybe this week, maybe next week.
And I don't expect things to go particularly
well for him.
We'll have more coverage of this on our Instagram
page.
Follow The David Pakman Show on Instagram
at David Pakman show.
Follow me on Instagram at David Pakman.
We have much more coming up today